[Music]
here we've got your soulmate options
calendar real Islander and a theoretical
third person let's call her as
strawberry mango twist okay close your
eyes
think about each of the women open your
eyes
the answer is real Eleanor how do you
know I don't but the minute I said that
you knew instinctively whether it felt
right well hang on let me think about
that how's it know
no more thinking GD just do something
indecision cost you so much agony in
your life right up to the very end I had
a little trouble writing my speech I
wrote 11 different versions weddings in
20 minutes buddy oh boy I mean please
run about 55 minutes apiece I'm really
hot is this air conditioner even working
yes it is you're just having a literal
meltdown also you're not dressed yet and
we haven't picked up the ring okay well
uh there's an issue there involving what
I consider to be unfair labor practices
on the part of the jeweler and we never
had a bachelor party because you can
never settle on a location or time I'm
sorry you were right this is too much
for me you should just leave me here and
go get married yeah here's the thing but
my wedding isn't for another month this
was a test to see if you could handle
being my best man and just as I
predicted you failed miserably oh no no
I mean I'm relieved but this is
embarrassing it's okay bud obviously I
prepared for this let's just go have a
nice night I'll buy you a beer 30
minutes GD
we've been trying to pick a bar for 30
minutes it is literally impossible to be
your friend you're incapable of making a
single decision look I know I can be
indecisive but what's the harm in taking
a few extra minutes to find the fun
Chiti and now the end is near and so I
face the final curtain what the hell
walk it off Lululemon I'll say it clear
I'll state my case of which I'm certain
I
alive I traveled eat live every day like
it's your last bite me I'm gonna live
forever [ __ ] ma'am
it's 1:30 to 21 so big plans this
weekend yep
I'm gonna sit alone in my house watching
wedding fails on YouTube drinking
margaritas through a twizzler straw
until I pass out on top of my vibrator
hi there give a second to talk about the
environment no buzz off whale humper you
know I see you here all the time and
you're always mean to me and it really
hurts my feelings it does because the
minute you're out of my line of sight
I literally forget you exist watch you
exist you don't exist they're bothering
me don't care if you die see why are you
like this
excuse me why am I like this no need you
don't know what I'm like look what you
made me do Jagger perhaps we should talk
more about that perhaps we should but
first another question about Camila
don't you think she and I would be
friends we have a lot in common we are
both Capricorn and we're both only
children I'm sorry I forgot about you
[Music]
congratulations you have all the
attention once again you are you really
good lord
Tommy you're a cocktail waitress now
honestly I think this is the right move
for you no it's just that my own sister
did even deign to invite me to her
little soiree so I had to weasel my way
in here like some common weasel I was
supposed to be in Haiti being
photographed helping people but instead
I delayed my trip by a day to come here
and tell you off no he came to do what
you always do make a scene and embarrass
yourself so I'm just an embarrassment to
you is that what you think of me
honestly I don't really think about you
[Music]
[Applause]
no no B what if it doesn't work we
thought of everything except for an
alibi and an escape route but we'll
figure it out as we go
you don't want to overthink these things
kind of freaking out here go boy I got
you this plan is foolproof and when it's
over we can finally have the lives we
deserve DiGiorno I am a safe installer
here to install it a safe so just a
point to where the guacamole money is in
our la installer the safe in the how you
say a place yeah hi we're being robbed
Jay down to his hats a golf ball and
he's got a terrible moustache we need to
get married now I do always in forever I
didn't so the plan was to pretend to
install a safe with your friend hiding
inside it he pops out steals the money
from the restaurant gets back in the
safe then you come in a none installment
I refuse to discuss my Fifth Amendment
rights until I concur with your attorney
sure look we found your buddy's plans we
know he was the brains you were just an
accomplice to get lucky you might get
probation Jason gone to jail no ma'am
Jason's dead he's suffocated in that
safe there are no air holes plus he did
a bunch of whippets while he was in
there which couldn't help at least he
died doing what he loved a bunch of
weapons now he's never gonna get the
life he truly deserved and I think he
got roughly what he deserved
Janet how many Janet's have there been
there have been 25 generations of Janet
each new update of Janet gains more
wisdom and social abilities fun fact the
first Janet had a click wheel so it's
like aging for a human you're you're
growing up that's how I like to think of
a Chiti I can't eat so every time
there's a new version of Janet I like to
take a piece of birthday cake and smash
it around where my mouth is janet has
learned and groans she's essentially
living a life with it kill her
not with that attitude we can't listen
man I'm dead you're dead we all died and
now we're killing her take a forward
I'm not what that means at all Eleanor
here we are just press that button in it
goodbye
Janet aah Chiti I can see that you're
worried and I just want to assure you I
am NOT human and I cannot feel pain ah
thank you that helps however I should
warn you I am programmed with a
fail-safe measure as you approach the
kill switch I will begin to beg for my
life it's just there in case of an
accidental shutdown but it will seem
very real cool so who's doing this me or
you uh I think I have to being a
bystander seems worse somehow okay here
we go
no no no please please please don't hurt
me I don't wanna die please again I am
NOT human I can't die I am simply an
anthropomorphize vessel of knowledge
built to make your life easier you're
pleading seems so real oh yes it is a
very effective failsafe ah you want a
robot killed right you have to do it
yourself
Eleanor Eleanor no no no please wait
wait wait Eleanor I have kids I have
three beautiful children
Tyler Emma and little tiny baby Philip
look at Tyler Tyler has asthma but he is
battling it like a champ look at him no
Eleanor look at them oh sorry Eleanor
again I'm not human this is a stock
photo of the crowd at the Nickelodeon
Kids Choice Awards that's right it's not
real let's do this right please I have
so much to live for no we're not even
here hey guys what's going on
now party was lame so I bailed then I
saw you so I followed you here oh look a
button
oh man I wanted to push that button
no cool dude whoa what happened to Jenny
she's dead guy I killed her not killed
remember Janet was not a living being so
she can't be killed
attention I have been murdered attention
I have been murdered attention I have
been murdered attention what do we do
Eleanor what do we do Chiti you just
murdered Janet we have to flee your
crime scene
[Music]
you